that's fine but y'all know what I'm
talking about you know what I mean I
understand what you're kind of where you
were going with that it's a I know you
were it's an old I didn't understand I
know that I debate a lot yeah
say what you need to say I've heard it
all before to be honest and hey you know
going back to my personal story because
everyone's telling me how I feel and my
unlikelihood you know that's fine I know
who I am as a person I know who I am as
a woman I'm glad you did and I just
don't want to participate in that I've
made mistakes in the past again like I
said not here to judge anyone or shame
anyone
um but I do believe your value does not
come from body count or lack of Body
Count
Your value for me comes from a higher
purpose ma'am and I'm not trying to
sound too sexual but body count does
matter because of the Wall Street the
value does go down it matters to you as
well yeah you only have one body for a
reason and that's why you're refraining
from sex yeah so it matters yes or no
you're judging a Woman by the amount a
penises that enter her vagina but what
about what about us judging you the
amount of times
you don't why does everybody want to
[__] Chris Brown we know he's [__] a
lot right you know he probably has an
STD or no we're not going out probably I
mean what do a lot of women want to [__]
Chris Brown
um do really I don't know they do he's
really skinny I don't know you might not
want to but I bet you he's not lacking
no [__]
also I don't think they're judging him
off of how many women
yeah you're a virgin on your wedding
that you have an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if you if you're a virgin on
your wedding day you have an 80 chance
of a happy marriage if you slept with
more than five people it drops to 25 so
much
[Music]
and I can't I can't tell the man what
his standards are for if he wants a
woman with a look like they said I don't
really care about a man's body count I
mean at the end of the day if we're
getting married you know like let's let
bygones be bygones but I can't be mad at
a man for you know not wanting a woman
with the body count over 10 yeah or five
I think for us like like definitely one
body is good like men like that right
but the the point is that you're you're
saying that you gave it up to one person
but this person might have to wait x
amount of time can you explain why why
is it that men are judging a Woman based
on how many penises enter her vagina
please tell me it's unattractive why
what it it just is like what does do you
think it just stretches out and it just
it's never gonna shrink back
I'm educated like I I know that a
woman's vagina okay if you're educated
experience chance why are you not
attracted to a woman that has I don't
know 30 body counts I feel like what did
I like her experience I do like the
experience and the skills that she's
bringing to the bed
I would like the experience for me to be
the next number but commitment no
because why would 30 other people let's
say the body count is 30 right 30 is is
decently high right
why as number 31 would I fully commit to
something that but probably 26 of that
those 30 bodies didn't have to commit to
because the brain is up here and it's
not down no but I think at the end of
the day it kind of comes down to men
feel like women have to do more to have
sex like we have to like I feel like in
their brains we have to like open our
legs and like is that how you feel the
point is we like exclusivity why would
we want some somebody that everybody
else has had right and they feel like
we're emotionally attached but you but
you you could have that you get to have
the liberty of having all the women that
you want but then you can't have like
the woman who wants a guy that you have
to teach in bed like come on I do I'm
actually like a good learning experience
okay this is Cap this is cat no and
that's all my friends I'm actually a
cougar so I actually like teaching boys
what to do because I want them to learn
what I like let me finish and the second
and the second reason why is because men
historically had to ensure paternity so
they didn't like a girl that slept
around because they didn't know if
they're passing on resources to a kid
that's theirs and you still see this
issue today that men are raising kids
that aren't theirs like there's a um a
DNA and that's very Noble there is a DNA
testing center no it's Noble if they
know but a lot of men don't know where
they said one out of four came back
negative and so they don't want to hoe
because she's a lot she's less likely to
be loyal what now a hoe oh Lord she was
saying uh there is statistics that like
show that if you the more body count you
have the you can see that the the
divorce rate is higher based off what
number she's at so there's like there's
statistics to kind of back it up or
moving in with a man or a woman before
you get married the odds of you getting
married to that person it goes down
dramatically yeah I just learned that
one recently actually so that's why
again I do not live with the man you
know I don't plan on doing that my
opinion on that and the whole divorce
rate with five or more I'd listen this
is this is what I believe my belief that
maybe you know because in my case I have
had multiple partners but I know what
I'm looking for and what in a man that I
want Americans I do want marriage so if
I know what I'm looking for and I like
what's up here it doesn't like I might
actually I think maybe I'll stay again
this is all hypothetical I don't know I
have a strong feeling that I would stay
with this man
for life because I know what I'm looking
for I know what I've already experienced
and I have no desire to go finding
something else unless we agree on
polyamory then what I'm too I'm too
selfish for that but I mean in regards
to like sexual encounters too like you
kind of brought up like yo no one wants
a virgin in bed I think that's a great
learning experience like a great time
honestly to enjoy with your partner
um and you know after you get married if
you're like oh man she's a virgin she
doesn't have any experience good I am
excited because you have the whole
marriage to explore those I was talking
about as a woman men want virgins women
don't okay
I want to address a comment it says I
don't mind it personally MJ says a woman
that has multiple sex partners is
looking for the next sex partner and not
a husband I would like to address that
I'm actually looking for a husband same
and I have had multiple what's your body
count you have multiple right now what
do you mean sex partners yeah what's
your body
I don't know if I want to say that
because I don't want to judge what's
your body count you have you don't want
to hear mine you have multiple sex
partners right now
uh yes right now correct okay I wish I
was you because I can't say that I gotta
wait till I get back to Brazil so
imagine this what are you talking about
I don't even understand what you're
saying why can't you I said you have
multiple sex parties right now meaning
like you're with me I'm dating I'm
dating I'm going around and seeing who I
match with because I'm looking for a
partner for life so multiple is at least
four right no two that's not multiple
dancers
that's a pair okay okay continue so to
me multiple means more than one means
more I agree with you okay so the
question so the question can you come
back to the question can you can someone
expand can I ask you real quick all
right hold on one second so it says a
woman that has multiple sex partners is
looking for the next sex partner not a
husband I want to address that because
as she said we both agree we are looking
for our husband now she's currently not
in sexual relations I am and so I want
to address them and say yes I am looking
for a husband I'm not looking for my
next sex partner how could you be
looking for a husband while having sex
with two dudes as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible